so is he crazy or continue
he believes he's mentally ill
but he may be the most powerful mutant
we have ever encountered
could we take a break
look at me i know what i am what's that
what's going on everybody it's warren
and what you just saw is a tiny little
teaser and perhaps a glimpse into the
future of what marvel studios has in
store for us as far as magneto in the
mcu
that's right today we have some pretty
epic reports stating that marvel studios
is currently
in the process of casting their magneto
for the marvel cinematic universe
now we know that mutants and the x-men
are coming to the marvel cinematic
universe
pretty soon so this doesn't come as a
huge surprise
but it is super exciting nonetheless and
what are the x-men and mutants without
one of their main villains and
also sometimes one of their main allies
the one and only
magneto and it's possible that we could
be seeing him
as early on as the one division series
i'll break down everything you need to
know about this new report in this video
but first if you're new be sure to
subscribe so you don't miss out on any
of the latest mcu news
and so you can enter this week's
giveaway for a chance to win a zombie
hulk funko pop i am picking a winner on
friday so to put these two reports right
now in simplistic terms it stated that
dan stevens is in talks
right now with marvel studios to play a
villain in the mcu
it is rumored that this villain is
magneto
the first report comes from an exclusive
from small screen and they say that dan
stevens is in talks to join the mcu
possibly as a villain now for those of
you who may not know dan stevens was the
star of
marvel and fox's show legion and he
actually already played a mutant in fact
he played one of the strongest mutants
there was
he played david holler the son of
professor xavier
and gabrielle holler so playing the
mutant wouldn't be exactly new to dan
stevens as he's already played a mutant
on screen
and he's really tight with marvel as it
is small screen says that they've been
told by their sources close to marvel
that dan stevens isn't talked to join
the mcu but
it won't be to play david haller aka
legion but they have actually quoted two
sources on their site and one says
dan stevens and marvel are currently
deep in discussions it's for a role in
the mcu
the movies and it could be a villain so
right here this source close to them
tells them that it's not going to be for
a disney plus project it's going to be
for
a movie then they quote another source
that says
stevens is in talks with marvel kevin
feige is super excited to bring him into
the marvel family
i'm hearing it's for a villain role not
legion
so a couple of different sources have
told them that dan stevens is being
considered for a villain
in the mcu but a report from
geekgossity.com
specifies which villain they have in
mind in the report mikey sutton states
stevens is being looked at for the new
magneto this time fitting within the mcu
rebooted for what is also being planned
to be a new cast for
the x-men but magneto is just one
character that stevens is being
considered for
and i'll explain this in just a second
but the report goes on to say
small screen reported that stevens was
being sought for a villain
and when mikey asked his sources which
villain they said that it was magneto
but
that feige sometimes auditions actors
for multiple roles so according to
geekosity.com the role that he's being
considered for right now primarily is
magneto within the mcu for the new x-men
now when the report talks about him
being considered for other roles as well
marvel does this a lot they keep a lot
of actors
on hold on retainer for certain roles
that they think would be fitting for
them within the mcu
jake gyllenhaal is the perfect example
kevin feige admitted that they must have
auditioned
jake gyllenhaal for several different
roles within the mcu until they finally
found that perfect role of
mysterio for him kevin feige also
recently admitted that they do the
same thing for keanu reeves they want
keanu in the mcu and kevin feige said
that for each movie that they're doing
or each project they talk to keanu
reeves about a certain role
they just haven't found that perfect
role for him yet
but when and if they ever do find that
perfect role then he'll get that role
and he will be in the marvel cinematic
universe
and this is apparently what is going on
for dan stevens right now
now we'll talk about if dan stevens is a
good fit for the role of magneto in the
mcu in just a bit
but real quick let's talk about the
importance of this report
the fact that dan stevens is being
considered for the role of magneto means
that magneto is not too far away from
making his mcu debut
this is huge news but now the question
is
when exactly is magneto going to enter
the mcu
well he does have one major connection
to the first
marvel phase four project that is
happening in january
and that is the one division series and
his connection is to the one and only
wanda now we know that the one division
series is going to be
a tv adaptation of a bunch of different
comics but primarily
the house of m comic in the house of m
storyline
wanda creates a new reality one where
mutants
kind of have their perfect world
spider-man is a celebrity married to
gwen stacy
captain marvel is a very beloved
superhero doctor strange is a
psychologist
and magneto is the ruler of this world
and in this comic storyline
not just in the new reality that wanda
creates but in the entire storylines
universe
magneto is actually the father of the
scarlet witch and her brother
quicksilver and it was this way for a
very long time but marvel would
eventually say that this wasn't indeed
true and magneto wasn't
in fact their father but the importance
here is that
one of vision is going to take from the
comic house of m
and in the house of m comic story
magneto is a very prominent character
and it's widely believed that the one of
vision series is going to actually start
addressing
mutants now right now there are just a
ton of theories out there as it stands
whether it's wanda creating a reality
where mutants are real and then that
reality becomes real in itself
or they simply introduce them we don't
really know what's going to happen
but marvel did give us a slight hint
in their new book the wakanda files that
is mcu canon meaning everything that is
said in the book
actually happens in the mcu we just
don't see it on screen
they talk about wanda and petro's
genetics
according to this book they were chosen
to be test subjects by strucker himself
because they had quote the appropriate
genetic markers that make them conducive
for human trial volunteers
so in this book that is mcu canon they
specifically
mention wanda's genetics and that she
has a certain genetic
marker there are also notes from dr list
and he says that wanda and patria were a
proven success where others
failed now he thought they succeeded
because of their hatred for tony stark
and that's what they led us to believe
in the movie
but what if it was something else what
if it was something in their genes that
the
mind stone awakened and of course you
all know what i'm talking about the
x gene so it seems kind of apparent that
they're going to explore this at least
somewhat in the one division series
which means that magneto could very well
indeed be on his way to the mcu
pretty soon now some of you have been
asking me on twitter
would dan stevens actually make a good
magneto and i think the answer to this
is absolutely legion had a very cult
following it was actually quite an
amazing show that came from fox
it ran for three seasons and 27 episodes
and dan stevens's performance was very
exceptional and you can see that again
in the clip in the beginning of this
video
he has great range as an actor he's able
to act very smoothly and then at the
same time
act very aggressively and angry he can
look very suave but he can also look
like a madman
all sides that magneto has and he's at
an age where he can commit to playing
this character for the next 10 to 15
years
because we know magneto isn't just going
to be in one film and that's it he's
done
magneto is going to exist within the
marvel cinematic universe along with
other x-men like professor xavier and
wolverine for a very long time
so overall i do think that dan stevens
would make a very good
magneto and if he doesn't get cast as
magneto i would like to see him play
another role within the marvel cinematic
universe but let me know what you think
about this do you think he'd be
a good fit and be sure to let me know
what you think about the wanda vision
series talking about mutants how do you
think they'll be brought into the mcu
let me know what you think in the
comments down below don't forget to
subscribe so you don't miss out on any
of the latest mcu news
give the video a like if you enjoyed it
and for live updates you can always
follow me on instagram and twitter
as always thank you all so much for
watching woof